tenemos aquí varias de las reglas de las
derivadas que hemos visto en los últimos
vídeos si alguna de estas reglas no te
parece familiar si te parece extraña
bueno pues te recomiendo que no veas
este vídeo porque lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es pensar cuando se aplica
a cada una de ellas además de ver
algunas estrategias y cómo podemos
modificar expresiones algebraica mente
para utilizar alguna regla más sencilla
pero bueno vamos a empezar con un repaso
rápido esta es la regla de las potencias
es una regla muy útil para tomar la
derivada de alguna variable elevada a
una potencia n por supuesto también la
podemos utilizar con algunas de las
propiedades de la derivada por ejemplo
con sumas de derivadas o con restas de
derivadas y de esa forma obtenemos las
derivadas de los polinomios por acá
tenemos la regla del producto si tenemos
una expresión y queremos encontrar su
derivada pero
además esa expresión la podemos escribir
como la multiplicación de dos
expresiones entonces su derivada es la
derivada de la primera expresión por la
segunda más la primera expresión por la
derivada de la segunda y lo repite otra
vez si alguna de estas reglas no te
parece familiar si alguna de estas
reglas es nueva para ti ponle pausa a
este vídeo y más bien observa los vídeos
acerca de la regla de las potencias o la
regla del producto y haz los ejercicios
de esta sección o bueno también puedes
ver los vídeos de la sección de la regla
del cociente regla del cociente y bueno
esta regla se ve un poquito más
complicada siempre tengo sentimientos
encontrados con respecto a ella porque
esta regla si no te acuerdas de cómo es
puede derivar la a partir de la regla
del producto como vimos en un vídeo
acerca de la regla del cociente
lo que hacemos es escribir a esta
división entre g de x como una
multiplicación x
elevada a la menos 1 pero bueno la
cuarta regla es la regla de la cadena y
lo repito otra vez si alguna de estas
reglas no te parece completamente
familiar más bien tienes que buscar
vídeos acerca de estas reglas porque en
este vídeo lo que vamos a hacer es
buscar estrategias de cómo resolver
derivadas y cuándo aplicar cada una de
estas reglas así es que vamos
directamente a eso supongamos que
queremos encontrar la derivada con
respecto de x de x al cuadrado más x
menos 2 / x menos 1 si queremos
encontrar la derivada de esta expresión
cuál de estas reglas utilizarías bueno
pues por aquí esta expresión se parece a
la de la regla del cociente podríamos
decir que esta es la expresión f
y luego que esta otra es la expresión g
de x y entonces podemos aplicar la regla
del cociente
activamente podemos hacer esto si
hacemos todas estas cuentas por acá
vamos a llegar a la derivada de esta
expresión pero en este caso en
particular nos conviene detenernos un
momento para ver si podemos simplificar
esta expresión y si lo simplificamos
seguramente vamos a tener que hacer
menos trabajo por lo menos vamos a tener
que hacer menos cuentas entonces por
aquí nos podemos poner a pensar en cómo
factorizar esta expresión y bueno es
igual a x + 2 por x menos 1 por lo que
estos dos se cancelan y esta expresión
se simplifica a x + 2 aquí estamos
buscando la derivada con respecto de x
de x + 2 y bueno pues es mucho más fácil
encontrar la derivada de esta expresión
que aplicar la regla del cociente con
esta expresión de acá aquí simplemente
tenemos que tomar la derivada con
respecto de x
x que es un 1 más la derivada de 2 con
respecto de x que es 0
así es que toda esta derivada se
simplifica y nos queda 1 ahora en este
momento cuando tomamos la derivada de x
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
utilizar la regla de las potencias así
es que si tenemos una expresión y
hacemos un poco de reconocimiento
algebraico las cosas pueden
simplificarse muchísimo pero bueno
hagamos otro de estos ejemplos digamos
por ejemplo que ahora nos piden que
encontramos la derivada con respecto de
x de x cuadrada más 2 x menos 5 entre x
nuevamente nos podemos sentir muy
tentados a utilizar la regla del
cociente tenemos aquí dos expresiones
que se están dividiendo pero en estos
momentos uno se puede detener a pensar y
decir oye esto lo podemos simplificar
para que sea un poco más fácil porque
esto que estamos dividiendo entre
x lo podemos expresar como una
multiplicación
ahorita simplemente me voy a enfocar en
esta parte de adentro del paréntesis de
la derivada y esto se puede escribir
como x elevada a la menos 1 por x al
cuadrado más 2 x menos 5 y ahora aplicar
la regla del producto pero hay una forma
todavía más fácil de hacer esto y eso es
distribuir esta multiplicación aunque
multiplicamos por este y por éste y por
este estamos distribuyendo esta
multiplicación en todos los términos y
recuerda que x elevada a la menos 1 es
lo mismo a dividir entre x entonces lo
que nos queda es x cuadrada dividida
entre x eso es simplemente una x
2x dividida entre x eso es un 2 y luego
menos 5 dividida entre x o bueno también
lo podemos escribir como menos 5 por x
elevada a la menos 1 y entonces tenemos
que tomar la derivada con respecto de x
de esta expresión que es mucho más
sencillo que aplicar la regla del
cociente o aplicar la regla del producto
a ver aquí esta derivada es simplemente
un 1 luego la derivada de 20 pero
finalmente por acá esto es un poquito
más complicado pero simplemente tenemos
que utilizar la regla de las potencias
aquí menos 1 x menos 5 es un 5 positivo
aunque ponemos el 5 positivo y luego
tenemos que poner la x elevada a la
potencia que tenía menos 1 pero entonces
menos uno menos uno es menos 2
así es que otra vez hacer un
reconocimiento algebraico de lo que
estamos
y hace que sea muchísimo más fácil
derivar lo bueno vamos a seguir haciendo
ejemplos de cómo reconocer y manipular
algebraica mente lo que queremos derivar
hace que la derivada sea muchísimo más
fácil de obtener supongamos que alguien
llega y nos pregunta cuál es la derivada
con respecto de x que por cierto estoy
aquí derivando con respecto de x porque
es la variable que estamos utilizando
pero funciona con cualquier variable
alguien nos pregunta cuál es la derivada
con respecto de x de la raíz cuadrada de
x / x al cuadrado ponle una pausa del
vídeo y piensa en cómo resolverías tu
esta derivada nuevamente podemos aquí
utilizar la regla del cociente pero hay
una forma más fácil de resolver esto lo
que hoy vamos a concentrarnos únicamente
a lo que está adentro del paréntesis
esto es igual aquí dividir entre x al
cuadrado
lo mismo a multiplicar por equis a la
menos dos y tenemos aquí la raíz
cuadrada de x en estos momentos podemos
utilizar la regla del producto pero lo
podemos simplificar todavía más porque
esto es igual a equis a la menos 2
la raíz cuadrada de x es x a la un medio
y ahora podemos utilizar las reglas de
los exponentes y nos queda x a la menos
2 más un medio que es menos tres medios
y listo al crear y aquí estamos tomando
la derivada con respecto de x de esto
nuevamente este es un ejemplo en el que
tenemos una expresión con la cual no
sabemos si usar la regla del cociente o
usar la regla del producto pero
simplificando esta expresión nos queda
suficientemente sencillo como para que
sólo tengamos que utilizar la regla de
las potencias aquí lo que nos queda
usando la regla de las potencias tomamos
el exponente lo pasamos al coeficiente
entonces nos queda menos tres medios por
x x a la potencia que tenía menos uno
menos tres medios menos uno es menos
cinco medios
y es que siempre que estés a punto de
utilizar la regla del cociente piensa si
no puedes simplificar la expresión a
veces simplemente tenemos que hacer
algunas manipulaciones algebraicas
también podemos hacer sustituciones
trigonométricas pero si se puede
simplificar la expresión sacar la
derivada se vuelve mucho más sencillo
una recomendación general que te puedo
dar es que si en algún momento estás por
ejemplo en un examen resolviendo una
derivada y sientes que es una ruta
demasiado complicada por ejemplo la
regla del cociente generalmente te lleva
por una ruta algo complicada esa es una
muy buena señal de que deberías
detenerte unos segundos y antes de
realizar todos esos cálculos complicados
tal vez puede simplificar un poco la
expresión y que la derivada fluya de una
forma más sencilla ahora vamos a ver
otro ejemplo esta solución no va a ser
tan clara en realidad depende de cuáles
sean tus preferencias pero digamos que
queremos tomar la derivada con respecto
de x
de 1 / 2 x menos 5 aquí por supuesto
también podemos aplicar la regla del
cociente diciendo que este 1 es la
función f x pero también lo podemos ver
así como la derivada con respecto de x
de 2x menos 5 elevado a la potencia
menos 1 y si nos vamos por este otro
camino podemos utilizar la regla de las
potencias y la regla de la cadena por
aquí la función de x es el polinomio 2x
menos 5 y efe compuesta por g
efe gx es toda esta expresión así es que
esta derivada es igual a la derivada de
la función de afuera evaluada en la
función de adentro por la derivada de la
función de adentro bueno dicho de otra
forma podemos decir que es la derivada
de toda esta expresión
respecto a la expresión que tenemos
adentro del paréntesis y luego
multiplicar por la derivada de esta
expresión ok empezamos tomando la
derivada de f de gx con respecto a gdx y
eso nos queda así tomamos el exponente
lo multiplicamos por el coeficiente aquí
estamos utilizando la regla de las
potencias y nos queda menos 2 x menos 5
elevado a la menos 2 esto es la derivada
de fg de x con respecto a hdx pero ahora
tenemos que multiplicar por la derivada
de g de x la derivada de lo de adentro
la derivada de 2x es un 2 multiplicamos
por 2 y la derivada de menos 50 entonces
ya terminamos el 2 es que prima de x
pero bueno déjame hacer un ejemplo más y
lo repito otra vez no hay una forma en
la que se tengan que hacer las cosas se
puede hacer de varias formas distintas y
eso es en parte lo que quiero
obsérvese en estos ejercicios las
múltiples formas con las que podemos
resolver este tipo de derivadas
digamos que alguien te pide que
encuentres la derivada de 2 x + 1 al
cuadrado ponle pausa al vídeo e intenta
resolver esta derivada por tu cuenta
bueno una forma es volver a aplicar la
regla de la cadena tomamos aquí el
exponente lo multiplicamos por el
coeficiente y entonces nos queda 2 por
la expresión 2x más 1 elevado a la 1 que
es el exponente que teníamos menos 1
pero luego tenemos que multiplicar por
la derivada de lo de adentro que es
simplemente un 2 pero esto es igual a 4
por 2 x + 1 y si queremos distribuir el
4 en este paréntesis esto es igual a 8 x
+ 4 esta es una forma completamente
correcta de resolver esta derivada pero
por supuesto hay otra forma de hacerlo
por ejemplo podríamos saber
arrollado esta expresión primero y
después sacar la derivada de cada uno de
sus términos y esto sería igual a la
derivada con respecto de x de 2x elevada
al cuadrado es 4x al cuadrado más 2 x 2x
por 1 + 4x + 1 al cuadrado y aquí
simplemente tenemos que aplicar la regla
de las potencias en cada uno de estos
términos
así es que pues utilizamos un poquito de
álgebra primero haciendo que la derivada
sea más fácil y por supuesto vamos a
obtener exactamente el mismo resultado
entonces la moraleja de este vídeo es
que te detengas a observar la expresión
que estás tratando de derivar observa si
hay alguna forma de simplificar la sobre
todo si te estás complicando la vida
usando la regla del cociente porque ésta
a veces es bastante difícil de recordar
y tienes que hacer un montón de cuentas
por lo que se puede poner
innecesariamente complicada muy rápido